the world will mark an important
Milestone as the global population
surpasses 8 billion people
weddings are back and experts are
predicting weddings to reach a 40-year
height we have been waiting to do this
for two and a half years after weeks of
flotation and fighting the new couple
has officially done the deed
full on crypto crash 32 billion dollars
just vanished jiggle jiggle BTS are
going on Hiatus Taylor Swift fans waited
hours online only to find the website
crashing I'm going to the
final seconds before impact
a fantastic day oh stunning yeah the
Blockbuster legal Saga between Amber
Heard and Johnny Depp my favorite thing
about the movie is like it feels like a
like like movie
the Russian president says a military
operation is now underway in eastern
Ukraine explosions and Air Raid Sirens
are ringing out in cities across this
country soaring new numbers from the U.N
on ukrainians fleeing the fighting we
cry we all have the feeling that we've
no homework
Russia now the target of more than 2 700
new sanctions in the world bracing for
food shortages Russia has suspended all
gas supplies to Germany possible
explosions along the north stream
pipelines gas prices soaring to the
highest average ever recorded Amazon
Microsoft meta announced 11 000
employees laid off 1200 Twitter
employees Calling it Quits I quit is
what's going on
inflation is much too high everything is
double up
these prices are totally outrageous I do
not have time for this
it's been the most incredible ride and
journey I've ever been on
we have finally achieved equal pay for
our men's and our Women's National teams
it's about damn time it is the most
controversial World Cup in the history
of football the Gulf States been under
intense scrutiny over the treatment of
Migrant workers the 2022 Winter Olympics
are underway Jamaica will compete in the
four man bobsled China's snow princess
is the queen of Big Air Russian figure
skater testing positive for a banned
substance I have tested positive for
coven 19. I will have to withdraw ba5 is
fueling yet another wave of covet
vaccines for children under five began
today
airline passengers can now decide for
themselves to wear a mask summer travel
this year comes with some baggage Kylie
Jenner takes a three minute flight and
yet they're telling me to recycle cans
soaring temperatures
14.2 degrees
Pakistan reeling from the devastating
floods caused by Monsoon rains we are on
a highway to fly Mattel with our foot
still on the accelerator hurricane Ian
has changed Florida forever he's one
could not continues because the water
was too much we are seeing tragedy
unraveling in front of our eyes
this crater hints at the size of the
explosion in Western Ghana
the government of Burkina Faso averted a
plot to take over the country today
154 people were killed in a crush in
South Korea another mass shooting at a
Fourth of July parade in a Walmart at a
hospital complex at a gay nightclub an
elementary school in Uvalde Texas they
let her baby gets slaughtered a major
Supreme Court ruling that could make it
easier to obtain a firearm license
anti-semitic incidents black transgender
deaths arising critics call it the don't
say gay Bill
the nation's highest court ruling to
overturn Roe v Wade
22 year old Masa amini was taken into
custody by Iran's morality police I mean
his death has sparked outrage
the Iranian Squad chose not to sing the
country's national anthem please be our
voice and don't let the evil regime kill
innocent people Palestinian Journal
Shirin Abu akla has been shot dead
thousands gathered for her funeral
procession
authorities in China are strengthening
their efforts to Stamp Out unrest over
stringent coveted measures
I want you to know how sad I am to be
giving up the best job in the world I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party I am prepared to give everything I
have Xi Jinping has become the most
powerful leader in China in decades hire
bolsonaro defeated by former president
Lula de Silva
Gabriel's youngest ever president
Republicans were hoping for a red wave
which didn't really pan out Georgia
Maloney's Brothers of Italy party
winning this weekend's election India's
first tribal person elected to the
highest Office of the land Buckingham
Palace has announced the death of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II
this is the end of an era
[Music]
Ukrainian forces are now on the
offensive they've taken more territory
in the past week than Russia has since
April nobody is going to break us we're
strong we're ukrainians WNBA star
Brittany Greiner is headed home I'm
about to sign the inflation reduction
act the largest U.S commitment ever to
finding climate change Cuba holding a
landmark referendum to legalize same-sex
marriage
foreign
[Applause]
every image is a new discovery and each
will give Humanity a view of the
universe that we've never seen before
thank you to the academy for letting our
Coda make history tonight and don't you
ever
it is a long journey to this moment in
my family it took just one generation to
go from segregation to the Supreme Court
of the United States history is not
about statistics and memorizing dates
and boring quotations
history is about people it's about human
beings
[Music]